vamos a comenzar el siguiente problema
que nos plantean y dice que el metanol y
aquí está su fórmula molecular que es
ch3 o h dice que se usa como combustible
en autos de carrera y en baterías de
combustible puede producirse por la
reacción de monóxido de carbono e
hidrógeno y la reacción que resulta aquí
nos la plantean dice aquí está el
monóxido de carbono aquí está el
hidrógeno y aquí se produce el metanol
entonces dice supongamos que 356 gramos
de monóxido de carbono y 65 gramos de
hidrógeno se mezclan y reaccionan ok
entonces vamos anotando estos detalles
tengo seo de monóxido de carbono tengo
356 gramos y de hidrógeno molecular voy
a tener 65 gramos ok entonces a partir
de esto me preguntan cuánta masa de
metanol puede ser producida y bueno esto
será muy similar a los vídeos que ya
hemos hecho anteriormente
de problemas de esta geometría y la
segunda pregunta que nos plantean y
estos digamos la parte nueva de este
tipo de problemas me preguntan cuánta
masa del reactivo excedente permanece
después de que el reactivo limitante ha
sido consumido y entonces para empezar
tendríamos que ver qué es eso del
reactivo excedente y limitante en
realidad eso nos está diciendo que es un
problema de reactivo limitante que hay
mucho o hay poco de alguno de los dos
reactivos que nos dan el limitante es
ese es el del que hay menos y dicta
cuánto se puede producir es decir a lo
mejor yo sí necesito cierta cantidad de
hidrógeno para poder hacer que esta
reacción se lleve a cabo pero si me dan
menos pues entonces me están limitando
la producción de metanol estamos de
acuerdo entonces además el que tenemos
de extra o el que tenemos tenemos de más
es el excedente el reactivo que hay de
más es el reactivo excedente entonces
déjenme ir anotando algunas cosas por
ejemplo
cuál es la masa molecular de cada uno de
ellos siempre es bueno a partir de esto
entonces vamos a hacer incluso digamos
una columna aquí que diga masa molecular
molecular y vamos calculando lo por
ejemplo para el monóxido de carbono pues
tengo un carbono y cada uno tiene una
masa de 12 y tengo un oxígeno y cada uno
tiene una masa de 16 por lo tanto esto
me da 28 gramos gramos
qué más tenemos tengo el hidrógeno
molecular por supuesto y tengo dos
átomos de hidrógeno y cada uno de ellos
tiene una masa de 1 entonces aquí lo que
yo tengo es 1 por 2 que son 2 gramos
ok entonces este aquí están las masas
moleculares es decir cada mol de cada
uno de estos reactivos tiene esta masa y
ahora lo que hay que checar es la
proporción en moles que nos dan de los
reactivos es decir me dan estas dos
cantidades en gramos de los reactivos
necesito a ver cuántos moles son
realmente de cada uno de ellos y ver la
proporción que hay para compararlo con
lo siguiente miren yo aquí voy a tener
que por cada por cada dos moles de
hidrógeno aquí tengo por cada
moles de hidrógeno requerido que déjenme
dejarlo así yo voy a necesitar en
realidad solo
molt un molde de monóxido de carbono
requerido entonces esta es la
proporciones tequio métrica por supuesto
tendríamos que comparar cuál es la
proporción que tenemos a partir de los
gramos iniciales que nos dan y antes de
empezar cualquier cosa hay que
garantizarnos de algo y que se los había
mencionado en el vídeo anterior y es
garantizar que la ecuación está bien
balanceada entonces vamos a empezar
viendo que haya la misma cantidad de
átomos de cada elemento tanto el del
lado de los reactivos como del lado de
los productos bueno vamos a empezar por
ejemplo con el carbón aquí tengo un
átomo de carbón acá tengo un átomo de
carbono en su pinta bastante bien ahora
también tengo un átomo de oxígeno del
lado izquierdo y del lado derecho
también sólo tengo un átomo de oxígeno
van perfecto solo nos falta ver que
tenga la misma cantidad de hidrógenos de
cada uno de los dos lados y aquí fíjense
tengo dos moléculas y cada una de ellas
tiene dos átomos de hidrógeno por lo
tanto tengo
átomos de hidrógeno mientras que del
lado derecho aquí tengo 33 átomos de
hidrógeno y 1 extra de este lado derecho
así que me dan 4 entonces tenemos la
misma cantidad de átomos de cada uno de
los elementos tanto del lado de los
reactivos como del lado de los productos
ok entonces vamos a proceder a ver
cuántos cuantos moles de cada uno de los
reactivos me están dando por ejemplo
vamos a empezar con el monóxido de
carbono en realidad me están dando 356
gramos de monóxido de carbono y fíjense
que por cada uno por cada mol que
dijimos que tenemos 20 28 gramos
entonces fíjense tengo 28 gramos lo voy
a poner aquí abajo de monóxido de
carbono por cada uno
de monóxido de carbono porque lo pongo
así bueno en realidad porque estoy
haciendo una conversión de unidades aquí
tengo gramos y esto me va a permitir que
como tengo gramos arriba y gramos abajo
de monóxido de carbono estos se cancelan
y simplemente voy a tener 356 en entre
28 moles de monóxido de carbono y ahí
tendré mi primer este mi primer digamos
resultado vamos a ver cuánto es esto
vamos a sacar tengo 356 sobre 28 y eso
nos da 12 puntos 71 4 vamos a dejarlo en
12.7
entonces tengo estos son 12.7 moles
moles de monóxido de carbono perfecto
ahora vámonos con el hidrógeno vamos a
ver qué pasa con el hidrógeno aquí yo
aquí me dan 65 gramos de hidrógeno ok y
chequeamos nuevamente hacemos un cambio
de unidades que por cada gemelo bajó un
poquito
ahí estamos bien por cada amor por cada
mol de hidrógeno digamos ahí lo tengo yo
voy a tener 2 gramos 2 gramos de
hidrógeno entonces simplemente lo que
voy a hacer es este esta división no
porque otra vez aquí se cancelan ok
estos gramos se cancelan y simplemente
me queda 65 entre 2 que eso puedo
hacerlo incluso mentalmente son 32.5 ok
32.5 y que unidades me quedan los moles
de hidrógeno entonces me quedan moles de
hidrógeno perfecto entonces vamos a
subir tantito aquí vamos a hacer ya la
proporción fíjense esta es la proporción
es tequio métrica vamos a ver cuál es la
proporción que tengo de lo que me dieron
inicialmente para ver cuál es el que
está en de más y cuál es el que está de
menos es decir cuál es limitante y cuál
es excedente
entonces fíjense vamos a poner arriba a
los hidrógenos tengo 32.5 moles de
hidrógeno
y tengo 12.7 moles de monóxido de
carbono entonces cuál es esta proporción
vamos a ver tengo 32
2.5 /
12.7 y esto me da a 2.55 9 voy a dejarlo
en 2.56 entonces de aquí lo que obtengo
de aquí lo que obtengo es que tengo 2.56
moles de hidrógeno aunque hay moles de
hidrógeno por cada gol por cada mol de
y monóxido de carbono
entonces fíjense que en realidad tenemos
para llevar a cabo la reacción
necesitaba dos moles de hidrógeno por
cada molde monóxido de carbono aquí yo
tengo más tengo 2.56 moles de hidrógeno
por cada molde monóxido de carbono
entonces eso me está diciendo que de los
dos moles de hidrógeno que yo necesito
en realidad tengo un excedente tengo
este punto 56 de extra ok entonces con
esto yo ya puedo concluir que el que
quien está en excedente quien es el
reactivo excedente es el hidrógeno y
quien es un reactivo limitante es el
monóxido de carbono ok
déjenme entonces ir anotando estos
detalles tenemos que h 2 el hidrógeno es
el reactivo
excelente
y tenemos este reactivo excedente y
además tenemos que un este un reactivo
limitante que es el otro entonces el
monóxido de carbono es
activo
limitante
otra vez porque estamos pensando en este
término de limitante bueno pues
esencialmente yo tengo un más hidrógeno
del que necesito entonces realmente
quién va a llevar a cabo las
proporciones necesarias para esta
reacción pues lo que tengo limitado que
es el monóxido de carbono si yo tengo
más hidrógeno del que puede reaccionar
entonces la cantidad de producto va a
estar determinado por el monóxido de
carbono ok entonces vamos a ver vamos
tomando este como base vamos a ver
cuánto metanol vamos a producir entonces
vámonos yendo a ver cuánto metanol
podemos producir entonces tengo ya que
obtuvimos 12.7 moles de monóxido de
carbono entonces tenemos 12.7 moles de
monóxido de carbono
y vamos a ver utilizando las las
proporciones es tequio métricas cuántos
moles de metanol puedo yo producir
entonces fijémonos que por cada gol por
cada de aquí arriba de la reacción
por cada molde monóxido de carbono yo
tengo un molde de metanol
entonces por cada mol
de metanol ch3 o h yo tengo un mol de
monóxido de carbono entonces si yo hago
esta multiplicación digo realmente es
muy sencillo verdad porque lo único que
estoy haciendo es cambiar las unidades
aquí puedo ponerle producido no perdón
producido este es requerido y el
producido es este
producido entonces lo que estoy logrando
aquí es simplemente eliminar estas
unidades los moles de monóxido de
carbono se cancelan y simplemente tengo
12 puntos 7 por 1 moles de metanol
entonces estos son
12.7 moles de metanol que son ch3 o h
producido
lúcido muy bien entonces ahora hay que
hay que tomar algo en cuenta cuál es la
masa molecular de el metanol ok ya
tenemos la cantidad de moles ahora
queremos saber cuántos gramos de eso
tengo entonces aquí tengo que el ch3 o h
vamos a hacer la cuenta la cuenta perdón
de c sé cuánto pesa la cee el carbono
tiene una masa de 12 y luego tengo 3
hidrógenos y cada uno tiene una masa de
1 luego un oxígeno y cada uno tiene una
masa de 16 y otro hidrógeno que tiene
masa 1 y esto si hacemos la cuenta son
12 3 son 15 + 16 son 31 y 1 son 32 ok
entonces que tenemos que tenemos 32
gramos
metanol
metanol por cada molde de metanol se
dice que suena un poquito a rimas pero
bueno
ahí está entonces vamos a ver ahora
cuántos gramos de metanol tenemos
producidos entonces hacemos esta
conversión aquí tenemos la cantidad de
moles cambiamos las unidades con este
factor entonces tengo 12.7 moles moles
de metanol
de metanol y vamos a multiplicar por
este otro número
que son 32 gramos de metanol
por cada mol
metanol
ahí lo tenemos otra vez que lo que
conseguimos cancelar estas unidades y lo
único que me resta es multiplicar 12.7
por 32 vamos a ver
y 12.7
32 32 y eso nos da 400 6.4 vamos a
redondear esto para que sean más fáciles
las cuentas y vamos a dejarlo en 406 406
me parece bien vamos a ponerlo incluso
con azul
entonces estos van a ser 406 gramos
gramos
metanol ch3 o h producido
producido
sensacional entonces si se dan cuenta ya
tenemos la primera respuesta de la
primera pregunta porque aquí en el
enunciado nos decían bueno cuánta masa
de metanol puede ser producida y justo
fue lo que acabamos de obtener hay que
quemar la memoria tengo a ver que son
406 gramos
entonces aquí las respuestas son 406
gramos
muy bien entonces ahora lo que nos resta
es ver cuánta masa del reactivo
excedente permanece después de que el
reactivo limitante ha sido consumido ya
vimos que el reactivo limitante es el
que determina toda la toda la reacción
así que ese se va a agotar mientras que
va a quedar algo del reactivo excedente
como su nombre lo indica entonces es de
esto hay varias formas de hacerlo por
ejemplo
la más fácil de ellas es utilizando la
propiedad de que la masa se conserva
entonces la cantidad de gramos que
tenemos del lado del lado de los
reactivos debe ser la misma cantidad de
gramos que tenemos del lado derecho
entonces por ejemplo aquí inicialmente
me decían tú tienes cuántos gramos de de
monóxido de carbono me decían
aquí están 356 356 gramos y también te
damos 65 gramos
del hidrógeno ok el reactivo limitante
son es el monóxido de carbono así que
esencialmente quién va a determinar
cuánto cuánto excedente vamos a tener de
hidrógeno pues es el monóxido y cuántos
gramos tenemos de metanol bueno ya lo
obtuvimos no son 406 son 406 gramos
entonces lo que podemos hacer es hacer
una sencilla operación que vamos a ver
cuántos gramos tengo del deje no ponerlo
aquí gramos
todos son gramos cuántos gramos tengo
del lado de los reactivos tengo 406 de
los productos y el excedente corresponde
al hidrógeno que que no reacciona
entonces vamos a ver tengo 356 65
podemos hacer esto
rápidamente 356 más 65 65 y eso nos da
421 aunque hay entonces tengo tengo 421
gramos
de reactivos
421 gramos de reactivos
y vos y tengo 406 de productos no que
fue solo del metanol que tengo 406 406
gramos
productos
de productos ok cuál es la diferencia
vamos a hacer esa diferencia que son 400
21 421 - 406 estos son simplemente 21
menos 6 son 15 granos
15 gramos de reactivo de reactivo que no
se usa
de reactivo no usado
ok esencialmente él sabemos que además
el reactivo excedente es el hidrógeno
aquí lo tenemos verdad entonces quién es
el que el que el reactivo que no se usa
pues es el hidrógeno entonces tenemos 15
gramos 15 gramos de hidrógeno sobrantes
ok 15 gramos de hidrógenos de hidrógenos
sobrantes perfecto entonces esta fue una
forma de realizarlo esta fue bueno hoy
yo creo que es la forma más fácil sin
embargo podemos hacer otra otra forma
por ejemplo podemos tomar
viendo cuál es la cantidad de moles que
realmente se utilizan en esta reacción
verdad porque sabemos que por cada dos
de hidrógeno se usa uno de monóxido de
carbono entonces vemos la cantidad real
de hidrógenos que reaccionan y eso nos
va a dar una cantidad cierta de moles
que además se la podemos restar a esta
cantidad si que es la que esencialmente
nos dan y eso el resultado lo
convertimos en gramos y no debe quedar
los 15 vamos vamos haciendo esto
entonces
aquí tenemos
12 puntos 7 gramos me dan 12 puntos
tenemos 12 puntos 7 gran perdón moles de
monóxido de carbono
estos son 12 puntos 7 moles de monóxido
de carbono los que reaccionan y vamos a
ver utilizando las proporciones stec yo
métricas que por cada dos moles de
hidrógeno requeridos
molés yo necesito un molde de monóxido
de carbono requerido entonces esta
conversión es sencilla cancelamos los
moles de monóxido de carbono y
simplemente me dice multiplica tu 12.7
por 2 que eso son 2 por 7 14 y llevo 12
por 12 24 yo no son 25.4 moles sale
estos son 25.4 y las unidades que quedan
son moles de hidrógeno
moles de hidrógeno requeridos muy bien
ahora todo esto vamos a hacer un cambio
también a gramos ok
estos son los gramos que necesito
encontrar entonces tengo 25.4 moles de
hidrógeno ok y esto sabemos que vamos a
dejar los moles aquí abajo para cancelar
los que por cada molde hidrógeno tenemos
que pesan o tienen una masa de dos
gramos de hidrógeno entonces cancelamos
moles como ya lo hemos hecho muchas
veces y tengo 25.4 por 2
esos son 50.8 entonces al final lo que
tuve son 50.8 gramos gramos de hidrógeno
requerido muy bien eso cuanto a ver
regresamos al punto inicial porque nos
habían dado 65 gramos
o sólo utilizamos 50.8 entonces vamos a
hacer esta sencilla resta y tenemos 65
menos 50.8 entonces 65 menos 50 son 15
y menos punto 8 son 14.2 14.2 gramos de
hidrógeno que pasó que nosotros teníamos
inicialmente o bueno lo que habíamos
observado donde lo tenía aquí que eran
15 gramos de hidrógenos sobrantes por
aquí obtuvimos 14.2 bueno no hicimos las
cosas mal simplemente esta diferencia se
debe a que redondeamos mucho en los
pasos intermedios bueno espero que haya
sido bastante útil para para ti y nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo